hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
cm.l2-3.4.4 analyzes the security impact
of changes prior to implementation
always important to read the directions
before you implement
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone try to understand all of the cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so in cmfc control cm.l
2-3.4.4 analyze the security impact of
changes priority implementation I have a
little joke about this control which is
it's kind of like a man reading the
directions okay nobody ever wants to
actually analyze what in the world of
security you know switch or control or
solution is going to do before they
actually just go throw it into place
right throw it up against the wall let's
see if it sticks and apparently somebody
thought for it and said that's not a
good idea so we better put a compliance
control in here and make sure that
doesn't happen now if you're in a larger
Network you're already familiar with
what can happen when you just start
implementing security without really
testing bad things happen heads roll jaw
jobs fly but the good news is the
process may involve reviewing security
plans and system design documentation as
well as conducting risk assessments to
determine if additional security
controls are required the objective of
the analysis is to is to assess the
potential impact of changes on the
security posture of the system and to
ensure that changes do not introduce new
vulnerabilities or degrade the
effectiveness of existing controls now
how about you guys but I once saw a
YouTube video and it had a dude with a
chainsaw between his legs trying to pull
the cord and start the chainsaw
that's kind of like implementing
security uh control or or implementing
security uh you know you know security
changes without analyzing whether or not
they're going to work all right so from
me to you because I care about you don't
hold the chainsaw between your legs when
you're trying to start it it's a really
bad idea and the impact I can I can do
that analysis for you it's not good we
don't want to do that all right let's
check out what what is what the
assessors are looking for on this one
and how to make them happy
um
they're actually only looking for one
thing apparently this is a pretty easy
control one they want to determine if
the security impact of changes to the
system is analyzed prior to
implementation I would never guess
that's what they were looking for on
this control no way would I guess that
maybe I would all right uh what's the
answer to it so again we're gonna say
hey security impacts for analyzing
considered both during ticket processing
and during quarterly risk management
meetings so again when we sort of look
at the whole framework of how we are
making ourselves compliant we can point
to these various meetings and standard
operating procedures and all this
documentation that we've developed
demonstrating what are processes and
procedures are for making sure that
things are realistically considered
before they're put into place and that's
really all you could ask for and so I
understand why there's really only one
thing they're looking for in order to
pass you on this control now at on call
I'll tell you what we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
all this dfars nist I torrents cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seal on a sunny day and we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you and if you look looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you okay visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance owners
roll it out until the next compliance
tip my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance I'll see you on
the next one
[Music]
thank you